Greg Anthony how are you Greg I'm just
trying to figure out my place in our
post-merger world Greg so would you
agree with the assessment that the game
was stolen by the Warriors last night
absolutely no doubt about it
Portland that's a game that ultimately
will probably cost them this series
and and I say that because you know like
after Game one everyone was one to write
them out because you know they got
handled but that you know you're gonna
get in a set of game series typically
even if it's an evenly matched series
one game you're typically going to get
it handed to you and I really believe
that Portland will probably handed the
golden state in the game of this series
but it's those 5050 games especially on
the road where you were the better team
and you lose those are hard to make up
especially against a two-time defending
champs especially when you think that
potentially Kevin Durant is looming and
he will at some point maybe make an
appearance in this series you've got to
take advantage of those opportunities
and quite frankly Portland did not they
just kind of caved they're down the
stretch did not execute well did not
make the plays and conversely that the
world champs did how does that happen
walk me through how just how a team
that's up fifteen and then up eight and
as you point out they know they've got
to get one in Oakland they know they
have to and they had their best
opportunity know Durant multiple
possession leads multiple times I mean
how does something like that happen when
you're involved in it Greg well listen
I've been a part of it on both end it
happens in part because Golden State's
will was stronger
they were tougher mentally and even
though Portland didn't necessarily
always make a play offensive ly you know
Golden State had to make plays down the
stretch you know they still had to come
up with big shots and big effort plays
even the last play with Iguodala against
Lillard that was a that was a hell of a
defensive play by Iguodala you know like
it's a 15-point lead at halftime
in today's game especially gives Golden
State is not a big lead that's not
insurmountable
like that's not really a big deal I do
think though that the pressure of the
moment sometimes not so much for Damon
CJ but for that supporting cast they
don't have a lot of guys that are as in
car as comfortable in those big moments
as does Golden State and then for the
guys for Golden State who may not be as
comfortable they get comfort because of
who they play with you know that plan
with Steph Curry their plan with the
Finals MVP and Andre Iguodala they're
playing with a klay Thompson a draymond
Green and guy and I'm not mentioning
Kevin Durant so that gives you a little
bit of confidence in those situations
and I just think that's ultimately the
difference listen the oldest thing
without Kevin Durant well this is the
core team that still won 73 games a few
years ago you know and had to get lose a
3-1 lead in the finals to lose the
championship so they're more than
capable of nns is beating anybody on any
given night it's just that you know if
you're Portland you get 41 points off
your bench your stars were solid you did
it you didn't turn it over that much
overall 13 times for the game now you
got handled on the backboard a little
bit that's that was a difference-maker
but that's a game where you feel like
you got a win you know when you look at
the stats if I just showed you the stats
blindly you would sell that team
Portland probably one's their game and
for them to not win it it can be
demoralizing it's hard for you to get
back up emotionally when you know you
gave that game away that 50/50 game that
you've controlled that you had and now
you look up and you're down o to Greg
Anthony here on the Richardson show Greg
we had BJ Armstrong and studio here a
couple weeks ago and he said out of all
the warriors that you cannot allow to
beat you that you focus on this one guy
you take this guy out and you have the
best chance of beating him he didn't say
Durant which obviously the injury gods
have removed and he didn't say curry
he said draymond and man yeah I believe
every last syllable of that certainly
after last
now he does everything it seems Greg I'd
love for you to put your expertise into
that you know what I dream a green is a
Hall of Famer I mean that's really the
best way to describe it and he you know
he reminds me of the of a John Havlicek
type you know he's a type of player he
just does whatever you need him to do to
win again I mean this guy had five block
shots last night you know he let even
seven assists curry let eleven assists
he had eight but he basically he let him
in rebounding chips in sixteen points
you know he's their emotional leader you
know he he just and the other thing
about him he makes he makes winning
plays that sometimes you know they get
negated but you know basketball at the
end of the day it rich it comes out
there some of them also econo
possessions right and what he does is
when you got a team as skilled as they
are when you've got a guy that you know
going into he's gonna get me eight or
nine extra possessions just because of
how he plays the game you know that's a
lot of possessions that's potentially
you know 27 24 points it's off of threes
but realistically you're looking at
probably fourteen points so he's got to
give me forget the scoring he's got to
get us a chance to get 14 or 15 points
extra every game just because of his
basketball IQ and and it that becomes
invaluable when you've got great players
like if you take Greymon off this team
in a lot of ways Golden State's Portland
that's really what they become they
become a you know a team with a great
backcourt they could probably win a
series or two possibly but there's no
way near contending for a world
championship
that's his value it's a it's amazing
what he's able to do night in and night
out Greg Anthony here on the Rich Eisen
show I mean you're just spitting truth
there as far as I'm concerned I mean
that you said a lot of things that maybe
people like we think is provocate
but I mean dream on with it's a six
career playoff game with five or more
blocks that's a Warriors franchise
record he's had seven straight games now
with 10 or more rebounds which he's
never done in his career before and it's
at the most important part of the season
certainly with Durant out seven assists
and it seems like many of them are
coming from either the the free throw
line or the top of the key I mean he's
spreading the floor he's he's slashing
to the basket himself a couple of
alley-oops last night I mean all
different manners of Hoops and it all
comes from him it really is amazing and
and I don't know how you beat it how do
you if you are Portland down o2 or
you're in the Eastern Conference Finals
which we'll turn to in a second what do
you do right now
Gregg what I'm not a fan of their
strategy in the pick-and-roll right now
like be the Blazers many people talk
about I don't think you can trap curry
in the pick-and-roll because of what you
saw like what draymond is doing is for
him is his comfort zone when you
basically if you think about a
pick-and-roll on the strong side when
two guys double and they kick at the
dream on you basically created a
transition opportunity on the weak side
he's gonna have a three on two on the
weak side because he's gonna make the
play right away like he's got to make
the right read whether it's got to be
the layup which you saw him take a lot
or the dunk that this is why Houston
even though they didn't beat him one of
the reasons Houston gives them more
problems is because they can switch
everything and they don't give you those
free ray they make you have to play five
on five over the course of the game and
listen even by doing that it's not like
you stopped curry very still that is
clay still gets his I just think that
the strategy of trying to double or
trying to you know like show and recover
those are tough against this team I just
don't and having said that now you have
to have the personnel that allows you to
be able to switch you know your bigs
have to be able to play in space and go
the state is just from a basketball IQ
standpoint
they're about as good as you could
possibly be it's why I think you know
they have a chance go down as the best
team ever when you look at what they've
accomplished and in essence this
five-year stretch if they were to go on
and win another championship and I know
a lot of old heads like I always talk
about you know back when we played how
much better the game is that's a bunch
of baloney
you are state a game played with the
highest degree of skill that we've ever
seen you just are and it is for anyone
to say you're not it's like what do you
think basketballs the only sport that
doesn't evolve but you know like it
doesn't mean the era that I played in or
others play didn't work they weren't
great it was the best that the game had
been at that point but the game
continues to evolve and grow we haven't
seen a Yanis on the Kubo Thomas is Shaq
on the perimeter think about this like
as Shaq on the perimeter that's how the
game has evolves Steph Curry we've never
seen Durant I mean it's just brilliant
to watch these guys operate and see
teams trying to come up with a game plan
to combat it well let's turn our
attention to the Eastern Conference
Finals Raptors in Bucks Game two tonight
the coverage starts on TNT with Ernie
Kenny Charles and Shaq outside again one
our pregame show 7:30 p.m. Eastern Time
that also includes the reveal of the
finalists for the 2019 NBA awards
that'll go down here in Los Angeles on
June 24th also on TNT so we saw last
night Greg in between games one and two
at games and one to a different
fingerprints it was there were different
games how do you think Game two Mike
differ from Game one of this series this
evening well listen i do think that i
don't think that Brook Lopez is gonna
have any kind of game you had right but
but let's not forget though Lopez was
the best player on an NBA team he was an
all-star like he's not a he's not
incapable of having an impact it's just
that this is why our team like they're
walking so good because they have a lot
of guys that can have a Brook Lopez game
so you're gonna gain play announcer
Arnall to try to limit his but we saw it
in the last series it might be George
Hill
it could be malcolm brogdon you know
Ilyas over like they've got a lot of
guys Meritage who could have a big game
because they've got those great ones
when you talk about honor the coop oh
and he's going to command so much
attention that the opportunities are
gonna be there for success bigger
picture if you're toronto though
cough cough yakima i like the fact that
he was more aggressive you know he
didn't shoot it well but he was
aggressive I think he's going to have to
stay aggressive Marc Gasol's gonna have
to I think provide something offensive
Lee and then serge ibaka has got to play
play i mean you know he's gonna have to
have the kind of impact he had in the
series prior against Philadelphia where
he was a monster at times for them
coming off their bench you know Toronto
doesn't have a ton of depth and I
thought Kauai got tired in this game
even though he got Kyle Lowry for 30
points I just think down the stretch
Kawara was worn down so they got to
figure out a way to get more balanced in
their offense and then they're going to
have to also I think you know they
defended the three well with the
exception of Lopez but they I felt like
they just did not handle the interior
very well from Milwaukee so that you
know those are things you can make
adjustments but ultimately look if
you're on the road you get over 108
points in Milwaukee
that's a game you should have a chance
to win and and they're just going to
have to figure out a way to get other
guys to give them more it's funny the
postseason I always tell people the
regular season kind of tells you who you
want to be but the postseason shows you
who you are and all season long I
thought that Toronto had more depth but
their depth has been nullified here the
last two series they really haven't been
able to get much of an impact for power
or damply
those guys haven't really been able to
do as much he Bach has been the one guy
that they could count on off their bench
and Nick nurse is going to have his
hands full because this is Milwaukee
team is very much like we saw with
Golden State four or five years ago when
Golden State went into that season that
they wanted and no one saw it happening
and they had that monster regular season
where they won 65 games
Milwaukee team is somewhat earth at
their best player took a huge huge step
and the guys that we didn't know whether
or not they were great players are
emerging Chris Middleton's really
he took the challenge defensively didn't
score well but that's the beauty of
their team he doesn't have to get 2025
in him to win he made the commitment I'm
gonna go out and battle against Kawhi
Leonard and he made quiet the most
inefficient he's been in the postseason
before he sent Greg Anthony into his
good friday here Chris Brockman asked
him our poll question go for it over
there Chris all right Greg when we come
back on Monday what's the most likely
headline Warriors up 300 bucks up three
Oh Brooks koepka winds pick in probable
wins the Preakness disappointment in the
Game of Thrones finale and I hope it a
disappointment in the Game of Thrones
finale although I had some
disappointment in you know the the
Pannell problem willing what what what
bothers you Greg um I just didn't get
much of us there's just you know I was
just killing like they say the way they
set up the war yes the nightwalkers I
thought was great right the anticipation
yeah and then they just went right into
the next one and I just didn't I didn't
feel like there were any I didn't like
anybody in that episode yeah I mean like
I thought I didn't because I just felt I
didn't like anybody in the episode you
don't for series I'm sure you if you
guys are as invested in it as I am
ya know like that's a that's a lousy
feeling to have yeah at the end of an
episode there was straight fire it was
straight fire literally figuratively
straight fire literally right and again
you know you're because now we'll say if
there is entry because we don't know
what comes next
I mean all can you know have speculation
and what-have-you but that I'm I'm gonna
go with the Warriors throw up 300k man
that would be uh I mean if they could go
into Portland Greg and win without
Durant they're up three Oh
and kur can just sit back and just tell
KD stay in the cold tub or whatever he's
doing I don't know stand mice you know
all that that would be remarkable I mean
that would be that would be you
unbelievable that would mean the
Warriors would be on a five-game win
streak
five wins away from a three-peat with
four of those winning games in a row
without Durant or four and a quarter
yeah without Durant I mean that would be
insane if that it would be and I think
it would be apropos to because Steph
Curry is fairly or unfairly
he's an all-time great but for him to be
at the helm at the forefront of what's
happened now granted other guys are
playing brilliantly as well we just you
know documented with Draya and clay is
in terrific form and Iguodala gives them
valuable valuable minutes no doubt about
it but at the end of the day you still
have to have the guy that kind of stirs
the drink and that's what Steph Curry
and well I mean I think Gregg we called
him the other day before I let you go
though I called him the the most
unassuming NBA superstar ever he doesn't
ask for anything it doesn't seem like he
doesn't demand it it finds him he just
does it effortlessly and and he's just
he's an everyman he looks like the
somebody that you could go up and say hi
to I mean he is the least
assuming superstar in the history of the
league I'm thinking yeah uh you know
it's hard to argue against that because
even you think are you like Larry Bird
used to talk a lot of smack right like
you know a lot of those guys
Steph doesn't talk he's humble you know
he's always got a second for whoever I
mean maybe like maybe I'm proud to have
him as the face of our league you know
it's pretty awesome like magic you know
what I'm saying where everybody wants to
a part of him and he's smiling and but I
don't know magic might have been very
demanding it doesn't seem like he
demands a damn thing it just no he's
what they call low maintenance that's
right
Greg thanks recall enjoy a chat we'll
chat down the line certainly before they
hand out the trophy all right but let me
know who's nobody is next coach at
Michigan - I hope it's JaJuan I think
Jalen gave him me gave him me the leg up
today where I think Jalen gave him a
little bit of an endorsement
I hope it's JaJuan yeah what do you say
I would love to see Jiwan I mean he's
paid his dues he's been on championship
teams at the highest level and I think
this is what he really wants to do I
think he'd give his all good find it to
make a successful look what Patrick's
been able to do in Georgetown I think
he's done a really good job there and I
think that bodes well for Greg thanks
for the time
appreciate it Greg Anthony 50 on both
Twitter and Instagram right there on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app